selon l'invité ce soir
bon ba veut qu'on parle je sais pas de
ma carrière au cinéma
ma carrière de chanteur ou ma carrière
d'humoriste ducasse la danse c'est l'an
mil est remis tu fais 1000 r ah oui j'ai
fait c'était ma première fois par les
trois premières doit parler c'était la
mienne alors vas-y vas-y ça donne quoi
bien c'est donner un truc un petit peu
comme ça mais bon c'est bien pas non
plus j'ai décidé de l'enlever finalement
désolé mais bon ça donnait un truc à peu
près comme ça mais comme j'étais plus
jeune j'avais encore la voix encore plus
aiguë et je pouvais c'était plus facile
de manier votre tessiture voilà
[Musique]
oui
est ce son
vous
à ses enfants
à
[Musique]
oh
des fous
mais
j'ai seulement chan chan
[Musique]
obama
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
you
[Musique]
oh
alors
m
oh
[Musique]
et
domino
oh
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
en avril au café j'adore
ce qui pourrait être extraordinaire
maintenant c'est si pour répond pour te
faire plaisir et comme me faire plaisir
à tous
laurent ce qui va sortir c'est pour
village avait un gardien
on a transféré sione l'europe on va pas
prendre albator ça va moins bien marché
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y mettez un
pouce bleus